para mantener un desequilibrio en el
intercambio el gobierno central de china
necesita mantener su moneda débil
artificialmente para hacer esto ellos lo
que en esencia hacen es imprimir dinero
y la usan para comprar dólares de eeuu
de esta manera aumentan la oferta de
johannes y también aumentan la demanda
por dólares y así mantienen débil su
moneda la siguiente pregunta que ustedes
podrían hacerse es qué hacen ellos con
todos esos dólares que compraron con los
yuanes que imprimieron bueno ellos no
quieren dejar esos dólares inactivos
prefieren recibir algún tipo de interés
sobre ese dinero así que en lugar de
tenerlo guardado todo en algún almacén
ellos prestan este dinero al gobierno de
eeuu y hacen ese préstamo al comprar
bonos y letras del tesoro
así que ese dinero que compraron con sus
suanes que imprimieron va al tesoro de
eeuu
y el tesoro de eeuu le regresa al banco
central chino bonos del tesoro y letras
del tesoro
estos son bonos del tesoro
cuál es el efecto de esto primero el
banco central chino está recibiendo
intereses por su dinero y ayuda a
financiar la deuda del gobierno de los
eeuu y algo aún más interesante es que
está creando una demanda a incrementar
por los bonos del tesoro y esto que
ocasiona bueno si aumentamos la demanda
de cualquier cosa se va a incrementar el
precio de esto así que el precio de los
bonos del tesoro letras y bonos del
tesoro va a aumentar la diferencia es
que las letras del tesoro duran menos de
un año y los bonos del tesoro duran más
de un año así que el precio aumenta y
qué sucede cuando el precio aumenta
significa que el interés que el gobierno
tiene que pagar sobre estos sobre esta
deuda va a disminuir el interés baja y
esto lo expliqué con más detalle en un
vídeo anterior así que si el interés
baja significa que el costo de pedir
prestado al gobierno de los eeuu va a
bajar pero esto también es el punto de
referencia para el costo de la deuda en
general así
en general esto afecta a las finanzas de
los estados unidos la deuda se vuelve
más barata dentro de los eeuu aquí
salman khan beckham academy para cnc